[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
salute to all the players selected at
the 2020 pro ball in Orlando and speech
to the portable Ravens for basically
filling the entire AFC side with 12 Pro
Bowlers this is the B are betting show
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book I'm cabby Richards and this is our
betting insider Kelly cash out Stuart
she's a pro bowler and hitting her best
bets that she won't say it so I'll say
it for her audience you're welcome for
another bag thank you to the Dallas
Cowboys who dominated the Rams last week
having another W - my best bet after 15
weeks my record stands at 12 2 and 1 on
the season have even fallen since week
one you made some nice bags of cash
let's keep it rolling with this week's
marquee matchups
the Texans - 3 at the Bucs total 50 and
a half my man Jameis touch and go it
sounds like he's gonna be a go that's
why the line hasn't moved here I want to
back him in the Bucs but man they are
banged up at the wide receiver position
but there is no way I'm laying points
with Bill O'Brien and the Houston Texans
just 1 in 6 against a spread in their
last 7 as a favorite so instead I'm
gonna bet the scariest bet on the board
for Saturday under 50 and a half I know
the total has gone over 11 of their last
12 games in Tampa Bay but I don't care
I'm following the sharp money under 50
and a half is the play bills plus 6 and
half of the Patriots total 37 I wanted
to make a case for the bills they got me
last week when duck Hodges threw four
interceptions against that defense Tom
Brady not throwing four interceptions
boys and girls I know buffalo has
covered all eight road games over the
past two seasons but I lean towards the
Pats and my man Bill Belichick to get
the best of Josh Allen Rams plus six and
a half at the 49ers total of 44 I've got
a really good read on this RAM scheme
either for or against all season and I
want to play them so badly here why cuz
they play so much better on the road
they've covered seven of their last nine
this games in San Fran but this San Fran
defense worries me with Jared Goff I do
lean towards the Rams with six and a
half but I don't think I'm gonna get to
the window with that one Cowboys - - at
the Eagles total of 46 last week the
narrative was Cowboys lost to the Bears
on Thursday night Kelly the Rams are the
better team don't bet the Cowboys and
what happened that's right the Cowboys
blew the doors off that Rams team what's
a narrative this week this team almost
lost to the Redskins they got lucky with
that backdoor cover they're banged up
Carson Wentz is an elite I can hear all
the talking heads all week long it
doesn't matter don't buy into the hype
Dallas Cowboys won in six against a
spread in their division versus a team
seeking revenge that's right they beat
Philadelphia in Dallas week seven ego
The Revenge Eagles plus two Eagles on
the money line Monday night Packers plus
five and a half of the Vikings total of
47 Aaron Rodgers has a chance to clinch
another NFC North title with a win or
tie who do I like in this game you guys
gonna have to wait until the end of the
show for my best bet let's recap all the
marquee matchups Saturday I like the
Texans bucks under 50 and a half lean
towards the Patriots in the Rams and on
Sunday I like the Eagles my best bets
coming up on the Packers Vikings for
Monday night point differential is a
great indicator of a team's overall
success in the NFL but you can still
find value wagering on teams with a
negative point differential sports
better bill Kraken Berg explains with
the end of the NFL season approaching
they're going to be many teams in
must-win situations
well the bookmaker also knows that these
scenarios are no big secret and they are
already factored into the lines so
therefore you are paying a premium to
bet on these must-win teams in my
opinion the other side of these games is
where their real value is as some of the
teams they go up against can't wait to
play the role of spoiler
thank you Bill Kraken burger for your
expert analysis he's on twitter at bill
crack man kelly why should we bet
against teams in must-win situations mr.
Kraken burger said it best we got value
let's look at an example in my week 16
cards stealers - three and a half of the
Jets total of 37 Mr crack man said I've
got a fade those teams must win
situations that is the Pittsburgh
Steelers this week I know the Jets are a
less than desirable pick here but the
Steelers have the Ravens on deck in a
perfect world my season win total would
cash today with the Steelers and then
the Jets would still get the cover I
know I'm greedy like that but I'll take
the Jets plus three and a half Cardinals
plus nine at the Seahawks total of 50
and a half social media yep that's right
betting against the Seattle Seahawks
once again and why because they are 2 &
6 against the spread in their last eight
as a home favorite Arizona 11 3 & 1 in
their last 15 road games
I like the Cardinals plus 9 Chiefs minus
6 at the Bears total forty four and a
half what's the narrative here well the
narrative is mr. risky isn't good
Patrick mahomes is don't buy the hype
true Biscay does well as a home dog so
to the Chicago Bears 11 two and one
against a spread their last 14
I like the Bears on Sunday night to keep
it close it was very cool to see patch
of home so for 340 in a blizzard last
week versus Denver he's definitely gonna
stretch that Bears defense on Sunday
night we have a clear picture of the
contenders and the pretenders and in
this week's model the public we start
with gray goo 63 who asks do you only
bet on games that mean something for the
last two weeks of the season
absolutely not I bet on things that I
can find value and things that fit
certain situation and this week that
fits the Jags of the Falcons remember
last week guys the Jags flat out quick
now the sudden the Falcons are making a
run to save Dan Quinn's job
you want to lay a touchdown with this
team absolutely not Matt Ryan has been
sacked 18 times in their last four games
Ridley's out Julio's hurt I like the
Jags +7 Bryan 387 asks if a team gets
beat as a straight-up favorite is there
any value in betting that same team that
got beat the following yeah Cathy this
one kind of varies by situation but it
does fit the narrative this week seyton
st. - - at the Titans what are the
Saints do Monday night that's right they
beat up on the Colts badly and the
Titans loss is a hold favorite - the
Texans but Tennessee six and two against
the spread their last eight games as a
home dog and they own the Saints teams
the Saints just won in five straight up
in their last six games versus Tennessee
I like the Titans here as the short home
underdog good luck to the Titans trying
to slow down that New Orleans offense
may the force be with you Kelly r2d2
c-3po and bb-8 are waiting for this
moment give me your best bet that's
right these best bets have just been
absolutely money this season you know
who else's money that's right my man
coaches em and we got to give them the
heart hands over here cuz he is just
printing cash 60 34 and 3 in his career
against the spread but Kirk Cousins in
primetime that's all I ever hear from
you guys you know who's great on Monday
Night Football this man right here six
and one against the spread in Monday
Night Football games this lines been bet
up the whole world loves the Packers and
the line goes up what is that oh that's
right that's reverse line movement boys
and girls the Vikings are the play on
Monday night let's recap all of my picks
for week 16 these are listed in order of
confidence on how many units I'd
recommend you bet on each I've got a
four unit plan the Vikings three units
on the Eagles entices also have two unit
plays on the Jags jets bears and the
Cardinals throughout the holiday season
were giving away swag bags for our 31
days of betting celebration each day as
a new topic is something has a pretty
wild point in case Kelly what's the
weirdest thing you've ever bet on back
in 2013 I got some good inside
information on
was gonna be the next pulse oh the guy
from Argentina was 20 to 1 so I'm gonna
take a flier on him
so I fine I'm donated way more than my
10% back to the Catholic Church I hope
you watch that cash in holy water we're
nearing the finish line of the 100th NFL
season and thank you so much for
spending so much of it right here on the
be our bedding show it's been presented
by the Caesars Palace sports book this
is our last show of the year cabbie I'm
so sad don't worry guys we're gonna be
with you all postseason long starting
January 4th for wildcard weekend be sure
to follow along on social @br underscore
betting for all of my picks and for your
chance to win some free BR merchandise
good luck on all your best and here's to
a profitable weekend
[Music]